okay today I'm going to talk to you
about an experiment to determine the
rate of photosynthesis so first of all
all I've done is I've written the
equation for photosynthesis there's
another video to talk through this more
but just quickly to summarize it's the
process by which plants make their own
food in the form of glucose so in order
to find the rate of photosynthesis we
basically remember the rate is just
essentially how quickly is this process
happening this experiment is to see how
light intensity affects the rate of
photosynthesis so I'm just drawing some
of the equipment right now so what we've
essentially got here is we've got a
conical flask and in the flask we have a
bung in the top and here we have some I
just draw this now some Canadian
pondweed so this pond weed is just in
some water right here so we can see it's
beneath the surface of the water what
we've got up here is we have a gas
syringe so this bit of equipment here as
a gas syringe so what happens is during
photosynthesis as we could see from the
equation it releases oxygen so that
oxygen travels up here and is collected
in the gas syringe you can then measure
and record the volume of gas which is
collected in the gas syringe just here
so now independent variable the thing
that we're changing on purpose we see
the effect of is the distance of white
light from the from the plants so first
of all let's have let's say we've got a
light here so here's my lamp giving out
white light and let's say that is 30
centimeters away from the pondweed now
what we'd have to do is this we have to
first of all leave the light here for a
little while for it to acclimatize
and then after little while we're going
to see how much oxygen is produced but
there's one of the detail that I forgot
to mention so far in this water as well
we have a chemical called sodium
hydrogen carbonate now the reason why
we've got this particular thing in the
water is it releases carbon dioxide into
the solution into the water rather so we
want carbon dioxide to be released into
this water because the pond we needs
carbon dioxide in order to float
synthesize so by having this in here it
just allows it gives carbon dioxide for
photosynthesis to be able to happen so
this is what we do we have a stop clock
right here as well and let's say I'm
going to time it for 15 minutes so what
I do is this I leave the lamp here I
allow it to acclimatize then I start my
stop clock I then see how much oxygen is
collecting the gas syringe so as the
pond weed photosynthesizes it releases
oxygen that oxygen goes up here and
collects here so I'm just going to
quickly show this here so my distance in
centimeters and my oxygen produced is
going to be in centimeters cubed so
let's say the first one the distance was
30 centimeters and let's say in that in
that 30 yes when it's 30 centimeters
away let's say it collected 15
centimeters cubed of oxygen ok the thing
that we have to do next is we have to
change the distance of the light so
we're going to move the light closer for
a second one so let's say we put the
light here this time let's say it's only
ten centimeters away now when you do
this you do several different values for
the distance of the line now the closer
the light the greater the rate of
photosynthesis so we're going to be
producing more oxygen per minute more
oxygen per second so as you can see the
oxygen will going to go up here and if
we if we had the lamp closer we'd
produce more oxygen so let's say at 10
centimeters away we produced I don't
know 30 centimeters cubed because we're
going to be producing more oxygen now
let me quickly show you how to find out
the rate of oxygen production so we tied
it for 15 minutes each of these
experiments is for 15 minutes so the
first one if we did 15 centimeters cubed
we just need to divide it by the number
of minutes which would give us one
centimeter cubed per minute this one
here because we had 30 centimeters being
queued being produced in 15 minutes this
would be 2 centimeters cubed per minute
so we can see the closer the lamp the
greater the rate of photosynthesis
because we've collected more oxygen the
final things we need to talk about are
control variables so these are the
things we need to keep the same to keep
it a fair test so first of all we want
it to be the same temperature what we
could do to control that is to have some
kind of water bath what we also need is
the same concentration of this thing
here because we want the same amount of
carbon dioxide available to the pondweed
and finally I've written another really
important one it's the same type and
mass of pondweed as well because
obviously if we had loads more pondweed
we'd producing more oxygen and it
wouldn't be a fair test so that's how we
can carry out an experiment to work out
the rate of photosynthesis thank you